wasup is a legacy character she's right
there on the cover of Avengers number
one finally every single character from
that first issue of Avengers is here on
the big screen we saw the original wasp
a Janet Van Dyne in a brief flashback in
the first movie and at the end of the
movie we finally saw a new suit and Hank
Pym realizing of course this suit
belongs to his daughter hope it's about
damn time but now in ant-man and wasp we
see her in all her glory
watch this she gets to wear this suit
that she's been coveting her whole life
she so desperately wanted to follow in
the footsteps of her parents who had
been incredible superheroes in their day
and so she's finally doing that oh as
this incredible capability and
incredible drive as a fighter as a
scientist to be this hero she's the
toughest one in the movie she lives to
be wasp she lives to be this superhero
man so follow my lead
this film is primarily a fun clever
emotional story of family because of the
quantum realm is where hopes mother
Janet Van Dyne the original wasp had
been lost presumably forever I was in
the quantum realm and I think I saw it
Janet now the mission becomes can they
go down there and bring back her mom I'm
not giving up this technology gets into
the wrong hands
it's just chaos and the stakes are so
high we don't have much time
and man wasp also connects directly to
Avengers for these characters are going
to be very important going forward and
teaming up
rated pg-13